so the best mantra that i have for  learning new stuff is that you replicate  before you iterate copy it before you  make it your own and the way that you  make it your own is that you copy three  four five different people's stuff and  then when you combine your learnings  from those five you'll have something  that's unique that's your own and if you  look at the greatest artists of all time  you look at picasso look at da vinci  this is how they teach artists they  duplicate what another artist was able  to do their style and then they mix it  and they make it their own and that's  how you learn in business and that's how  you learn in life